quelques mots d'abord sans gêne cahier
qu elle m'a dit tu es tu et de l'anglais
merci pour l'intérêt que les médias ont
accordé à cette affaire veux vous
remercier de tout coeur des vignes et
des eaux et des jeux n'avait jamais
donné d'entrevue donc je vais faire de
mon mieux pour vous répondre
bien alors maintenant si vous avez des
questions votre réaction au verdict tout
d'abord face aux cadors je suis
satisfait de la sentence le jour où on a
rendu le verdict
je pense que le système judiciaire
canadien est juste et équitable
de mon point de vue personnellement j'ai
perdu mon fils
évidemment c'est un situation
irrémédiable j'ai entendu la sentence
j'ai tout de suite appelé les membres de
ma famille at a rich or die est connoté
alors je leur ai dit puis il avait reçu
la sentence la plus dure et j'en suis
très heureux même si la procédure est
très longue la procédure équitable
en ce qui me concerne je repars avec la
conviction que le système judiciaire
canadien est juste
ok
il a eu une conférence de presse tout de
suite après le la sentence
monsieur linh à ce moment-là a exprimé
une déception parce qu'il n'avait pas
entendu le prévenu a exprimé de regrets
quant au parking va pas dire autre chose
à deux doigts de nice enterprise jury
simon tonolito j'allais y joue un record
qui tient toujours à gagner un génial
basquiat et à la cei oui c'est exact
à newcastle aéro paris wang n a jamais
eu de cornillas talent et oui seulement
acheté à tirer un trait la sentence
j'aurais voulu communiquer avec lui et
lui demander pourquoi c'était arrivé
pourquoi il avait fait ça j'ai beau
santino mais jusqu'à maintenant donc ces
démarches n'ont eu aucune suite
je suis venu pour le procès avant tout
parce que je pleure monfils une autre
raison c'est que je suis venu ici pour
essayer de comprendre ce qui était
arrivé pourquoi c'est utile et là dessus
je repars sans réponse voilà c'est tout
demande une question sur son épouse zeng
jingyan elle n'est pas en bonne santé
alors qu'il est les médecins la soignant
elle voulait venir mais elle n'était pas
en état de venir ici alors c'est très
difficile pour la famille mais je sais
qu'un fonds a été créé pour vous venir
en aide vous voulez faire vous voulez
savoir ce qu'on fera de ce fonds à
compter de maintenant ou quand il sera
rentré
alors sa mère mon épouse n'est pas en
bonne santé maintenant ce sont les
médecins donc qui s'occupe d'elle à ce
moment ci je suis venu ici donc j'ai
passé quatre mois ici j'ai dû laisser
mon emploi alors comme je dis ici je ne
pouvais pas travailler bien sûr bien sûr
je suis encore abattu et je ne suis pas
en état de travailler tout de suite son
fils perdre mon fils pour moi c'est
d'avoir tout perdu sauf en 2012 hervé
alors en fait j'ai tout perdu j'ai tout
perdu sur le plan affectif j'ai tout
perdu sur le grand financier donc sans
parler d'autres choses
voilà
y'a des ingénieries alors il va rentrer
en janvier vous pouvez vous nous parler
de ce côté votre vie ici pendant le
procès vous voulez au tribunal ou à
l'extérieur
les deux sont des cas isolés
oui ça les aide à trouver le temps très
long
le tribunal nous avait accordé une
petite pièce vidéo à canal pendant le
procès donc il y avait de la
documentation vidéo que je ne pouvais
pas regarder la cour nous avait fourni
une petite ul c'est lorsque ces éléments
de preuves étaient présentés dont nous
pouvions placer grand coeur placé
masqué donc l'écran pour ne pas voir
c'est une vidéo d'enquêtés insupportable
parce que pour moi donc comme maire
physiquement je ne pouvais pas regarder
ces images je pense que le tribunal donc
nous a créé bien traités canon d'or du
tribunal il n'y a pas grand chose à dire
donc j'ai loué j'ai loué une chambre
donc il n'y avait pratiquement vielle de
télé pendant le procès donc sa taille
mais moi je ne pouvais pas bien dormir
pendant le procès je me sentais très
fatigué
j'aime paix
de 10 miles white le bon pendant ces
deux mois
bon mais je fais ont blanchi
il
ce que vous auriez quelque chose à dire
monsieur man iota au home and the
machine la zone non je n'ai rien à lui
dire
il ya un mot en chinois donc qui dit que
fait pire qu'un animal mais je voudrais
quand même dû demander pourquoi il a
fait ça
j saunders ce qu'il a fait est
terriblement cruel qu'il a fait est
inqualifiable
quelle était la relation entre eux deux
ce qu'il a fait n'est pas comment dire
il n'y a pas de mots font pour pour
qualifier ce qu'il a fait alors à quel
moment ce qu'il rentre chez lui et
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que seront les
prochains mois pour lui dit vous voulez
savoir ce qui va faire pendant les
prochains mois oui quand il rentrera
chez lui
oui et ce qu'il fera
je n'ai pas encore pensé à ça écoutez je
suis malheureux je n'ai pas pensé à ça
alors je rentre en janvier
ok tout jeune ami non mais odier joue à
domicile
alors oui il va continuer bien sûr
reprendre contact avec ses connaissances
là bas j'ai quelques amis donc à
l'université concordia ici avec lesquels
j'entends rester en bon tu as en contact
il ya aussi une communauté d'étudiants
chinois ici à montréal avec lesquels je
compte bien rester en contact
je tends à une clé dans le tuning show
sera aussi multi vous qu en cas d
attention car en même temps j'étais
terrorisée est loin d'être certain la
question porte sur précisément le
contact qu'il a eu avec les étudiants de
concordia
de quoi s levon par l'idh alors nous
savions déjà
et quand on contacte quand j'étais
encore à pékin qui terminent tard il m'a
dit m'a dit donc à ce moment là je leur
ai dit que je voulais venir à montréal
en fait auparavant j'avais même jamais
entendu parler de la ville de montréal
donc je seulement entendu parler des
villes de toronto et de vancouver au
canada
alors quand il m'a dit tu voulais aller
à montréal moi je savais même pas où
c'était savait pas au principe à cette
ville alors il est venu de pékin à
montréal et il avait fait sa recherche
sur internet avant de venir ici votre du
tigre ya'bad à la demande et certains de
ses amis donc ce que montréal est une
bonne ville un bon endroit et moi je lui
ai dit je pense d'abord à ta sécurité
il m'a dit morale c'est très bien et
c'est une ville très sécuritaire et m'a
dit qu'il aimait beaucoup donc la ville
il a choisi de venir ici
regardez ces lignes je lui ai dit moi je
ne connaissais pas la ville en fait si
toi maintenant tu appris de ces
informations et que tu te sens sur très
bien il sa décision fink et est ce que
c'est encore une fois donc je lui ai dis
donc si tu penses que c'est une ville où
bonneville
oui à toi de décider je te laisse libre
c'est alors comme ça qu'il a décidé de
venir à montréal et d'étudier à
l'université concordia et il a fait donc
des études avec eux majeur en
informatique
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé c'est
ce qui est arrivé
alors votre ville votre fils a choisi
moi c'est que vous ne connaissez pas est
ce que vous avez pu voir donc ici à
maurane plus ce que votre vis à
découvert ici comprendre un peu les
raisons pour lesquelles il a aimé lui la
ville de montréal écoutez je suis venu
trois fois ici
mais encore une fois avant de venir ici
moi je ne connaissais pas la ville façon
générale moral
très bien hier c'est une belle ville et
les gens ici sont courtois trente années
ted ginn un windows mais même si cette
tragédie m'est arrivé j'ai reçu la
sympathie de très nombreuses personnes
ici
bien sûr je suis venu ici à trois
reprises et chaque séjour a été
d'environ deux mois et à mais tendaient
des gens qui me connaissent et me
reconnaissent très souvent les gens
veulent communiquer avec noah il
voudrait me parler mais je ne peux pas
communiquer avec eux quand je lui parle
ni anglais ni français ni hôpitaux alors
il y a des gens très chaleureux donc
qu'ils voulaient me réconforter tous
voulaient me consoler mais nous ne
pouvions pas communiquer au niveau de la
langue nous pouvions simplement
communiquer au niveau du coeur battant
driss consoler
touchet je comprenais ce qu'il voulait
me dire ce point de vue là je veux dire
que montréal est une ville très amicale
il ay ay si beaucoup de gens chaleureux
je suis très reconnaissant pour la
sympathique on m'a exprimé
quel statut de service et celle du jeu
fait en quoi internet j'ai lu je le
donne perdant 7 secondes
johnny jour canadien
je n'ai comme la question pour certains
éléments de preuves qui ont été
présentés au procès et qui venaient
directement du fils de monsieur linh
le golden la bêtise et vidéos
alors il y à un journaliste de londres
qui avaient été en contact avec manioc
tard avant ces événements moi je n'ai
pas très bien compris de quoi il savait
parler mais je sais qu'il est venu
témoigner au procès et à ce moment là
j'ai su qu'ils avaient parlé je pense
que ce que le journaliste a dit au
procès est vrai que je n'ai pas vraiment
pu comprendre le détail de ce dont il
avait parlé mais j'ai compris de façon
générale
alors on pousse question propre au delà
du lien donc entre son fils alors
personnellement comme entre mon fils et
moi les relations que nous avions été
très étroite
mais monfils est encore plus proche de
sa mère passe en chine
j'étais très trip mon travail après
qu'il soit venu ici à montréal donc nous
n'avons pas communiqué aux tellement par
téléphone mais nous avons communauté
donc par internet dont nous avons parlé
c'était surtout donc du travail et nous
avons parlé aussi de sa sécurité
donc non ne t'inquiète pas ici c'est
très sûr et les gens s'ils sont très
gentils et moi je disais à mon fils donc
même si c'est un bel endroit il y a des
gens qui peuvent être dangereux il faut
être prudent et au-dessus j'osais cas de
mauvais temps alors je lui ai posé des
questions donc sur ses études
et je vais poser des questions sur son
emploi parce qu'ils avaient soi et c'est
ce dont on a parlé on a parlé donc de
ses études de son travail et de sa
sécurité
nous communiquions donc une fois ou deux
par semaine par internet
mais sa mère communiqué beaucoup plus
souvent avec lui alors au canada il n'ya
pas la peine capitale en chine à peine
capitale
eghezée c'est ce que vous trouvez que la
sentence est assez sévère
oui c'est vrai nous avons la peine
capitale en chine mais ici au canada
donc ça n'existe pas les systèmes
judiciaires diffèrent d'un pays à
l'autre
ici il a reçu ici au canada la sentence
la plus sévère
tout ce que je peux faire c'est de
respecter le système judiciaire canadien
s'agit pas d'essayer d'imposer le
système judiciaire chinois ici au canada
donc d'après ce que j'ai vu ce qui s'est
fait ici est juste et équitable et en
fait part que nous respectons le droit
canadien
au début donc j'ai pensé à ça la
possibilité donc que le procès se
déroule plutôt en chine qu'ici au canada
début donc j'ai posé la question j'ai
demandé s'il serait possible de faire en
sorte que le procès se déroule en chine
mais aussi dans les vosges travaux dict
ap un temps canon mais ici ensuite on
m'a dit on lui a expliqué qu' il n'y a
pas donc il n'y a pas de possibilité
donc devenir que l'on procès en chine
sur quelque chose qui s'était produit
ici au canada donc il fallait que le
procès se tienne ici au canada
alors pendant le procès est ce qui est
arrivé à comprendre la logique ou fin du
système judiciaire canadien s'est passé
difficile à comprendre mais s'ils sont
vraiment très lent très lent et très
long car les jeunes qui atteint générale
je pense que le système judiciaire
canadien et bien je pense que le juge
donc on était très bien il sait la
procéder de façon très équitable
il a donné des indications au jury donc
pour leur expliquer le sens de la loi
kenny quart d'heure
là on l'a fait dans ma tête
alors est ce qu'il ya des choses qu'il a
trouvé étrange donc à propos du système
judiciaire canadien des choses qui l'ont
surpris peut-être alors une chose très
étrange c'est d'abord que l'accusé n'ait
rien dit les témoins bien sûr on était
invitée elle apparaît mais le l'accusé
n'a rien dit du début à la fin il n'a
pas dit un seul mot
alors ça j'ai trouvé ça très étrange
alors son fils a voulu venir à montréal
est ce qu il lui a expliqué pourquoi est
ce que c'est une ville particulièrement
ouverte ou quelles sont les raisons qui
ont amené son fils à choisir montréal
n'a pas expliqué pourquoi il m'a dit que
c'était une ville qui était qui était
bien matic les gens ici étaient
accueillants mais il ne m'a pas donné
d'autres raisons qu'il voulait étudier à
l'université concordia pour prendre une
maîtrise en informatique
encore une fois je ne savais rien de
montréal alors c'est un nom qui est un
peu long qui est un peu étrange en
chinois donc on
est ce que monsieur linh envisage de
revenir à montréal ou au canada en dépit
de tout ce qui est arrivé là
oui je vais revenir
est ce que pour moi donc la grande
majorité des gens car le gars sont très
bien le canada en général c'est très
bien même si cette tragédie m'est arrivé
on ne peut pas dire donc le canada comme
tel est mauvais j'ai dit plusieurs fois
à monfils il faut vraiment faire
attention il faut vraiment être prudent
même si la société est très bonne il
peut y avoir des individus dangereux
mais il n'y en a que quelques uns
d'entre nous n'a la plus grande partie
jeanson crée ce que y en a cure et
sympathique
l'avocat de la défense a fait état d'une
rencontre qu'il ya rencontré donc
monsieur ligne dans l'ascenseur avec les
avait échangé quelques mots est ce qu'il
peut nous parler de cette rencontre avec
l'avocat de la défense
est-ce que c'était le jour de la
sentence
je n'en suis pas certaine
c'est peut-être le jour où la sentence a
été rendue mais c'est que l'avocat de
défense indique dans l'ascenseur il
avait rencontré monsieur linh qu'il
s'était donné la main qu'ils avaient
échangé quelques mots
il veut vérifier vraiment à quel moment
parce que ils se sont peut-être
rencontré à quelques reprises je pense
qu'une fois et il a rencontré monsieur
leclerc où il n'y avait pas d'interprète
et il ya eu une autre occasion où il a
rencontré m leclerc où il y avait un
interprète
donc il y avait bien été à près de
cesser oui oui j'aimerais préciser il y
a eu deux entrevues il y à une fois donc
où il était donc maître leclerc et lui
dans l'ascenseur était seul il n'y avait
pas de tapoter ne pouvait pas
communiquer mais il ya une autre
occasion donc où ils se sont rencontrés
en présence de nos terres près car là
ils ont pu échanger quelques mots
de quoi de quoi est-ce qu'ils ont parlé
qu'est ce qu'ils se sont dit
mais au total je la trouve à southgate
nous sommes salués nous sommes donnés la
main il n'y a pas pas signé bras ni un
accès à tout âge je lui dit écoutez je
ne vous je ne vous ai pas je ne vous en
veux pas parce que je sais que c'est
votre travail c'est votre responsabilité
de défendre cet homme vous êtes un
avocat donc alors je ne vous en veux pas
que je pense aussi c'est ce que je lui
ai dit n'avons pas eu une longue
conversation
m